所以AI就是協助思考,但不能取代我們,就是我們要去,我們自己要去判斷這樣
對,好,大概就是這樣
然後底下有生成一些,就是我前面講的東西的一些小測驗
okay because you give me more time so i can ask you in english more questions so what do you expect
to learn in this class when when you when you see the teacher give you the the concept like the
Scientific Learning Model Concepts, CLIO, Bilingual and also the AI Agent to assist you to learn the programming or the subject content.
What do you think you can learn from this case?
就是我想要學到的東西是
因為之前如果直接叫AI幫我們生成東西
通常都是生成一個檔案
或者是一個
就比如說一個PPT
或是一個Google表格之類的
就Excel這樣子
對
但是現在可以學到的是
叫他幫我們改
我們在寫程式裡面的東西
就是他直接介入寫程式
然後告訴我說
哪些程式碼可能需要改這樣子
就是我覺得這是我期待可以學到的
然後還有是
因為之前不太有寫城市的課
就至少大一沒有
所以就是
這節課就可以學到
很多跟城市有關的東西
然後再借由城市
就是因為深層城市嘛
然後我們可以去改他的註解
然後直接讓他幫我們畫圖
就我覺得蠻有趣的
OK
ok and because you do not upload your file into the github
so i i want to know
uh why you didn't finish this job
哦只是我
不知道怎麼唱成唱曲
所以我等一下去改一下哦
就是我好像沒有做到最後那一步這樣子哦
ok so i hope you can finish your job
before you leave the class
OK 好 我們再次掌聲感謝彭德安同學
OK Next one
Next one 陳奕恩同學
嗨 大家
好 我叫陳奕恩 然後
這是我
請AI幫我做的網站
好
先一個小核心 我不知道為什麼他做出來的時候他的標題要67 你看
沒事好
接下來就是我要介紹這堂課的新手冒險指南
我跟AI講說 讓他可愛一點 有趣一點
他就把老師變船長
大家有看過地心冒險嗎
老師就是裡面那臺船長 我們就是上面的組員
Ready for adventure go
Go OK
OK 第一個
新手裝備包我覺得很酷
這可以點到可以
有它的
進度條 還有漸層
我覺得蠻帥的
對 這個
AI蠻酷的
我叫他給一個
卡通一點可愛一點
他就給我這個很可愛的 對
好的
然後再來是這段課要學什麼
Geo Fixes
然後
雙語呈現 上一次我不知道這什麼東西
但我
對 這我不知道
但雙語
也許剛剛老師上課的時候
就是這堂課必備的
然後還有剛剛用到的資訊AI工具
我們這堂課就要學這三個東西
他們都整理好了
但我比較不知道為什麼是
它有一個正點跟繁衍
這我就看不懂了
是這個東西
然後接下來是老師給我們的第一堂課
闖關地圖
我覺得應該這樣設計起來非常的精確
他有時間他要做什麼
也有詳細老師會做什麼事情
他都幫我處理好了
再來是老師給的探究密集
CER思考法
主張證據跟推理
這個呢很幫助我們好好的理清問題
譬如說我們看到一條斷層一條Fault
我們可以說它是張列或聚合或是錯動
那它的證據是什麼
譬如說是張力的話
我們就可以看到說它是不是底下有
Uploading的那個Mentor就是低含柱
上升的低含流
或是說它在兩側是不是有螢幕的板塊
促使它形成張力的環境
然後進而用我們的證據去推理出
這個板塊到底它實際上是什麼狀況
它到底是張力還是聚合還是什麼狀況
這是覺得還不錯的
然後他也升給我 我覺得還蠻清楚的
但我覺得這可以再大一點
然後這個是老師給我們的金句卡
覺得很好用
We observed that many earthquakes occurred around Taiwan.
The map shows the distribution of active floods and volcanoes.
This evidence strongly supports our hypothesis of subduction.
We can explain this pattern by plain tectonic movement
然後可以聽與發音
它的發音我不知道耶
對 這是AI幫我弄出來
它給我一個發音的一個按鍵
很好用 大家可以聽聽看
OK 這個就算了 不聽了
好 下一個
AI協助者不是答案機器
我覺得這個也很棒
為什麼呢
因為如果你叫AI跟他說我要這個答案
它只會給你一個答案
但如果像剛剛的課程
如果你遇到問題 你是問他說
我哪裡出問題的 哪邊跑不動
他也跟你說我是不是缺藏什麼檔案
我是不是多了空格
我是不是多了什麼東西 所以他跑不動
所以你AI是幫助你釐清你的錯誤
而不是跟他說我要什麼答案 對
但有一個比較難受的是
我上禮拜用AntiGravity的時候
這個網站的Plant它不見了
Okay, I have a similar question for you.
What do you expect to learn in this class?
Yes.
First, initially, I think I should learn in some hypothesis
or some movement of the pentatonic,
or like what kind of volcano, or the moho, what is,
what happened in the moho, or in the systematic wave,
really love or whatever why move I buy what is motion but I think this is cool
yeah is cool not my exciting but I think I should learn it more yeah okay okay
thank you so I I want to share you some experience about speaking English when
when I was know I need to speak English in the class,
I also felt some nervous or some pressure or some,
to fear, some fears,
I'm afraid of making some grammar error,
something like that.
So, but however, eventually I think
I'm just doing the communication.
so I don't care the grammar error or some sentence is not precisely accurate
I think the most important thing is maybe we can speak the word very clearly
then you will understand my key point very quickly even some some word some
some grammar is not totally 100% correct.
I think that's okay.
So I trying to do that,
but why I'm going to do this?
Because I think if I can speak English more often,
and then I can improve my English ability.
So I will try to do this in the class
because I will lecture the class many, many years.
So I think this year,
maybe I'm looks like not so speaking fluently,
but next year I must better than this year
and next, next year will be better and better.
so that's my my strategy so I want to share you this this concept is it
because I think that the beginning is the hardest when we can make a step
forward and everything will become easier so I think you very good you can
and try to speak English is a very good thing.
And I hope everyone can do that.
And finally, I still want to say,
we are not in English class.
But why we choose English,
why we still need to use English bilingual teaching
in this class is that it's because
Because English provides us some structure, thinking structure, or concept, like the claim, evidence, and the reasoning. So if we follow the structure, the concept, it will help us to learn the subject, learn the content of this class.
so that's the target for using English in this class
ok so我們再次掌聲感謝陳奕恩同學的報告
謝謝
我看一下現在幾點
現在55分
好最後我要講一下那個3D列印
我們那5分鐘可以很快的講一下
請同學看一下那個
E-Class這裡
這個安裝3D列印程式裡面有一個
我剛有一個網址
好像找不到
這個
這個叫Open Topography
我把這個網址給大家
幫我按掉
謝謝
我放在桌上就可以了
然後大家連到這個網頁上面
Open Topography
然後這有個Find Topography Data
也許我直接給這個網址就好了
我再給一次這個網址
好這個Find Topography Data
然後這邊呢我們可以
看你想要畫哪一個地方的海底地形圖
假設我想要畫這個夏威夷的這個
ASPA的這個Chain
然後我們可以直接選一個Region
這裡點一下Select a Region
然後這邊就可以把它框起來
然後底下可以
選一個DataSet
然後下載它的TIFF檔
然後就可以
再利用這個檔案去
去建立那個
去建立TIFF檔
然後用這個檔案去建立3D模型
Select Agent Region
好像跑掉了
然後這個TIFF檔
如果太太大的話他會下載不了
然後可以把它變小一點再去調整
調整他的解析度
然後這個是這是一個方法
然後另外一個方法呢就是
從剛剛的這個地方
我們可以跟他說輸出一個
數值地形的資料
然後有了那個資料之外
不管是TIF檔還是數值資料
我們可以再跟
ChurchBD或Gemini
跟他說
請他生成3D列印的
檔案格式
叫STL
這樣
然後最後他會
產生這個檔案給我們
然後我們就可以利用
利用這個3D列印的
這個
這個程式
這個Bamboo Studio
然後
把它安裝到你的電腦裡面
用它用這個程式把它開啟
開啟我們做好的那個 stl 檔
然後在裡面可以做3 d 的
可以翻轉那個程式
那個圖形
然後再做調整
然後最後就是用這個
這個程式去做列印
把成品印出來
那我今天沒有
講的很完整
但是大概的流程就是
我們要先有數值檔
那個數值檔就是要
可以從網頁上得到
也可以從我們的GMT就可以輸出數值檔
你可以問一下AI
我們現在已經有框一個地體構造
像我這樣已經
我框了一個
譬如說這個是臺灣
然後我下一句就可以跟他說
請將這個地方的山高水深的數值檔輸出來給我
然後他就會有一個檔案給我
可能會放在這裡
然後就把那個檔案下載到電腦裡面
然後再把它丟到Gemini或ChangeBD
然後上傳上去
跟他說請幫我轉換成3D列印的檔案格式
然後他就給我那個格式之後呢
我再用這個軟體開啟就可以列印了
所以他的步驟大概是這樣
那今天我先大概講一下
那我們反正是下禮拜會帶大家來做
然後做完就把檔案給我
然後我回去就開始印
然後就印完我就會帶來給大家
你就會有一個模型
你選的那個區域呢
最好是跟你的作業二要一樣
這樣子才比較有意義
因為作業二我們會去探討
這個地方的地理構造的特徵
還有火山或是地震的特徵
然後我們會試著去判斷
它是什麼樣的板塊邊界
然後原因是什麼
跟地體特徵還有地震活動
火山活動有什麼關聯性
這些都是大家在寫作業二的時候
要做的那個思考的問題的內容
但最後的最後
我們想要看到那個地理構造
不只是在熒幕上
我們可以看到一個實體
可以在手上翻轉
所以就要靠這個去把它做出來
然後我把它印出來
這樣子
好 那我們今天就到這邊下課
好 謝謝大家
下課
有問題同學可以留下來
再問問老師